- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is, prove them wrong.
Over to you Guillermo del Toro.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- You know, when they say,
I would like you to do this for me
and I produce a lot of
first time film makers
but I don't produce all
first time film makers,
that approach me and I say,
look if I say no and you give up,
I'm sorry to tell you but
it's the wrong job for you.
Because you live with
rejection for decades,
sometimes as a director,
and you end up making the
movie you want to make.
So, if I say no, that doesn't
mean I'm right or I'm wrong,
you just say, (expletive)
him, I'll show him later,
you know, I'm going to make it
and that fat bastard is
going to have to say,
I was so wrong and hit
himself in the head,
because he didn't do it.
And I think that's the thing to do,
is like show us, don't
tell us, do the things.
And if you do them wrong,
but you do them in your own terms,
that's how I define success,
failing in your own terms.
- So, this is an interesting one for me
and I'm conflicted.
I'm conflicted with it
because early in my career,
I was very motivated by the little man,
by the haters, by the
nay-sayers, by the nonbelievers,
by the people who told me
I couldn't do something
and that was fuel for me to
go out and prove them wrong
and show it in their faces
and say, look what I went out and did.
Whether it was making my Believe by video
that the little man told
me that would never do well
and that was over or
almost two million views.
People who didn't believe in my brand,
people who told me I was the
worst speaker at the agency
and that motivated me
to want to get better.
And so, that helped me in
the early days of my career.
But, I honestly think that it
comes from a place of insecurity
and I would love to encourage you guys,
to get to the point where
you're not motivated
by what other people
think of you, good or bad.
Where the self-motivation, the
self-confidence is so strong,
that it doesn't matter what
somebody else says about you.
That you want to go out and do that
because you want to go out and do that,
not because somebody
makes you want to do that.
Your motivation needs to come from here
and not from out there.
And I'm saying this,
knowingly understanding that
earlier in my career,
I was very motivated by the
little man and the haters.
That actually helped me get some success
and so maybe it's just the mindset
and space that I'm in now,
having had some success.
But, I would love to see you guys
not care about the people who
don't like what you're doing.
The people who don't like your work,
the people who tell you
you're not talented,
the people who feel like you're
never going to be a success,
the people who look at
your product or service
and say, that's the worst
thing I've ever seen,
you're never going to make it.
If your motivation is
only to prove them wrong,
then it's not coming from a great place.
Where I'd much rather you be more powerful
and let that negativity
just pound off you.
The more you get success,
the more negativity you're
going to have by the way,
and the thicker skin you need to build.
And the less you want to focus on
what negative people are saying.
Where understanding, there's
a lot of people out there,
even if you haven't seen one yet,
there's a lot of people out there
who badly need what you could give them.
Where if you were to
unleash your inner talents,
your abilities, your
confidence, and create
and gift that to the world,
there's a lot of people who will love it.
And focus on them,
focus on the positivity,
and focus on doing the
thing that you want to do,
as opposed to doing something,
to prove somebody else wrong.
That's my take, the question today is,
are you doing your business
to prove somebody else wrong
or is it because you deeply
want to make it happen yourself?
I'm curious, do you agree with
younger Evan or current Evan?
Leave in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
So, thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one one word is,
much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I make up every morning
♫ Espresso keep my going
Hey Believe Nation,
we're looking at doing at
Top 10 Rules of Success
on Guillermo, so here's a sneak peek
at some of the clips we're
considering including.
I hope you enjoy the bonus.
- What I try to do is,
to connect deeply with the
audiences that like what I do,
even if the audience at
large, does or doesn't,
it makes no difference to me.
I make weird movies, no
matter what size the movie is
and they're not for everyone
and a lot of people may be puzzled or say,
why do you do this?
But I only do things that
I hope speak to somebody
in the fideistic way that I
was spoken to by people that
got a high on their own supply.
Because I get high on my own supply.
I make the movies because I want them
and whether it's robots
and monsters duking it out
or oppose to war, fable,
or whatever it is,
they're done because I want to see them.
My father bought a few libraries because
he won the lottery in Mexico.
And he heard or thought
that he needed a study,
so he built a library in the house
and he had a big desk.
He never, ever sat on that desk
and he bought books, sort of by the foot.
So, he bought an encyclopedia
and an encyclopedia of art,
an encyclopedia of health,
and a classics from literature.
And I read all of them
when I was very young
and especially the
anatomical section (laughs)
of the medical encyclopedia
proved very useful.
But I was, I became sort of a
bookish, disease obsessed young kid
and I discovered things like,
The Last of the Mohicans,
Hunchback of Notre Dame,
Frankenstein, Jane Eyre,
and Jane Eyre and Frankenstein were
two of the books I liked the most.
- [Interviewer] So, how
did you make the transition
to being a film maker?
- Oh, I started doing films
when my father, again, traded.
He had car agencies, car salesmanships,
and he traded a car for
some Super 8 equipment
than money and he brought
in a Super 8 camera,
Super 8 projector
and first of all, I
bought some Super 8 films
in San Antonio, Texas and one
of them was the Crimson Altar,
with Boris Karloff and I
bought a few strange runs
and I burned them in the projector from
watching them in reverse
and forward again and again,
and then I
- What were you looking for?
- I loved reverse, like the basics of film
are always magical, reverse, slow motion,
things like that,
they're always beautiful.
When you see a balloon
pop and then it comes,
it's always beautiful
and there's a great shot in The Red Shoes,
where the feet come in
and the laces tie up,
that is magical and it's
just reverse photography.
So, when ever I was watching it in
reverse I was like, oh my god!
So, I watched them backwards and forwards,
but then, I bought in the pharmacy,
back then, the drugstore,
I bought a Super 8 cartridge
and I put it on the camera
and I shot a little movie with my dolls,
my Planet of the Ape action figures.
And I projected it and
it's the most beautiful,
no one has ever, no time, have I ever had
the sense of elation that I had then.
Because I said, I did that
and it's on the screen!
And it was fantastic.